let's go my eggo
[Music]
you
hey youtubers is Charlie grab your egos
season 2 is coming hey youtubers is
Charlie grab your egos season 2 stranger
things let's break it down
HP Lovecraft eat your heart out the
great god Cthulhu tentacles coming from
the sky I totally love this so this is
just the beginning there'll be a lot
more season 2 stranger things happening
so be sure to subscribe to get
everything and if you think of anything
that you really want me to do a bonus
video on while we're talking about this
trailer just let me know in the comments
below
so a lot of you probably saw the teaser
picture of the ghostbusters this is in
1984 that's the year that Ghostbusters
came out so this is a year after season
1 but the dimensional portal is still
open will came back coughing up those
slugs from the upside-down world in the
teaser language that Netflix has been
using is that the world is upside down
the entire world the big monster at the
end with the red clouds looks very war
of the world so it's almost like our
world is now becoming or being taken
over by the upside-down world so there's
the will thing to like is the things
that he's drawing turning into actual
things so he draws the picture of the
demagogue the demagogue manifest does
that mean that he is also creating all
these problems too because there's a
drawing of that big giant monster that
we see at the end of the trailer so a
lot of people felt like the fact that
wil didn't come forward in ask for help
when he came back when he was coughing
slugs up is because it had happened in
the past and he didn't want to be taken
away but 11 is back they left the aygos
at the end so that kind of told you that
she was coming back I don't think that
anybody actually thought that she was
dead but they opened this with the funny
aigo trailer preceding her so it's just
meant to remind you that this takes
place during the 80s get you in the mind
of that time period the other big theory
about all this craziness the upside-down
world the demagogue was did 11 have some
responsibility in creating it because it
always seemed to stay in proximity to
her whenever she showed up it seemed to
show up she made advantage by taking it
back to the upside down world herself
[Music]
no more
[Applause]
[Music]
so she's connected to the upside-down
world in the same way that will is they
just haven't explained that yet it's one
of those things they have to pay off in
season two this alternate dimension
because I actually do think that it is a
real place and it fundamentally changes
the people to spend time there for any
extended period so with the dimensional
portal open a lot of those things will
be running loose on earth there you get
your ghostbusters but also people will
be changing themselves so the whole
season is supposed to address the
consequences of will spending that week
in the upside-down world all this crazy
stuff at the Department of Energy they
added a couple big cast members too that
are big callbacks to 80s flicks like
this there's Paul Reiser from aliens
making you think about the demagogue
like wondering how much Ridley Scott
craziness is going to be happening in
Sean Astin from Goonies so of course
it's going to be awesome they released
this viral teasers it tells you a storm
is coming a lot of people decoded it and
thought that it meant that the season
was going to be dropping September 8
2017 but they actually revealed that you
know Ghostbuster cosplay Halloween
costume or really more of a hat tip to
the release date so it's actually coming
on October 31st Halloween this year so
that's when all the episodes will drop
they're really blending the idea of what
is real what is fiction what is the game
so the fun Easter Egg really from that
first episode if you go back and
re-watch the series is it's a game they
play the Dungeons & Dragons almost tells
the exact story of what happens during
the entire series shadow grows on the
wall behind you swallowing you darkness
it is almost here please it what if it's
the demagogy
Dark Ages for so screwed if it's the
demagogue an academic boarding an army
of chocolates charging to the chamber
chocolates told you good cheer that that
touchdown boom boom I think come from
the chocolate ice know that I came for
something
my deep [ __ ] well you're arching I don't
know where ball they'd have to roll a 13
or high or risky caster projection so
real [ __ ] fireball the impact
protection never go get inside of him
selling human bickering it stops towards
you oh oh yeah so they might lay Easter
eggs in the first episode of season 2
that way where they have some sort of
moment or a game or a conversation that
foreshadows everything that's going to
be happening but Netflix isn't holding
back anything they have these teasers
where they say monsters are coming
they're dressed as ghostbusters so
they're going to be lots of demo gorgs
running around people turning into
monsters things going crazy it's going
to be awesome
and get a load of the episode titles
they've already released them all
there's 9 episodes instead of 8 like
season 1 so episode 1 - episode 9 here
we go Mad Max the boy who came back to
life talking about will the pumpkin
patch the palace the storm talking about
these red storm clouds the Polliwog the
secret cabin the brain and the lost
brother so we can talk about what those
episode titles might mean in future
bonus videos but I will be doing a
couple of season 2 videos as many as
possible it's a little harder to do
videos for every single episode for
something that drops all the same time
so usually like what the Marvel Netflix
stuff I have to change the way I do the
videos just a little bit but it's a long
ways off we're going to be kicking about
this all here is going to be great let
me know like what are all your guys
questions in the comments below it's one
of those series that's very ambiguous
about things so it just lends itself to
a lot of theory crafting there are a
couple newer younger characters the
title the lost brother might be one of
those new younger characters but they'll
probably reveal a whole bunch more
information through the rest of the year
so I'll do new videos as they reveal
stuff but let me know what do you guys
think about this and everybody was
freaking out about it just because it
seems so crazy by the end just remember
you know David Cronenberg anything from
the 80s is fair game in terms of genre
in other related Netflix news
iron fist is going to be dropping March
17th of course I'm going to be doing a
bunch of videos for they'll probably be
a new trailer very soon in the next week
or so so just look out for that in if
there are any iron fist or Marvel
Netflix bonus videos you guys want me to
do also let me know in the comments
there's a lot of Netflix stuff coming in
addition to all the regular TV and movie
stuff it's going to be great while you
wait for that you can click here to
rewatch that Guardians 2 trailer and you
can click here 3 watch the Iron Fist
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
in the next video
[Music]